[Music]
you know I I have to show this you
posted a picture and have to I want to
show this a home remedy for migraines
yeah cuz you you tried a home remedy for
migraines you get bad migraines and you
toasted them yeah this picture this is
you were they bag bag of peas on the
back of your neck this doesn't work
someone on reddit suggested this and
just as like she did it yeah yeah why do
you sit you've got your feet in hot
water and then you put your head with it
was cold I've tried so many things I
found that excedrin migraine works
really well it's not if you take it but
if you jam the bottle into your eye
socket but don't take it
I also the best remedy I've found though
is using my vibrator on my eye and this
is serious I have the magic wand which
is like the the most powerful vibrator
and it you just put it in and just shake
your eye but here's the thing
i I've done this twice now this is the
first time I've done it the first time I
did it it my eye got swollen from all of
the like the vibrating and this is
supposed to fly home on Thanksgiving but
this is how I woke up you sure this is a
real picture of what
you look same that was me like mom and
dad I'm not coming home that was from
your you did that to yourself yeah and
my boyfriend says I look like I can put
character from Lord of the Rings I don't
know what gothmog I think
you